hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 3 hört zu und
spricht nach
wie alt sind sie
wie alt
sind sie
wie alt bist du wie alt bist du ich
29 jahre alt ich bin 29 jahre alt
sind sie verheiratet sind sie
verheiratet
nein ich bin nicht verheiratet
ich bin ledig ich bin ledig bist du
verheiratet bist du verheiratet
ich bin verheiratet
ja ich bin verheiratet
woher kommt eric woher kommt eric er
kommt aus schweden
und aus schweden woher kommt usher woher
kommt sie kommt aus indien
sie kommt aus indien wo wohnt daniel
und daniel er wohnt in zürich
er wohnt in zürich wohnt aurélie wo
aurélie sie wohnt in basel
sie wohnt in basel
wer ist das wer ist das das ist meine
familie
das ist meine familie
das sind meine kinder
das sind meine kinder das sind meine
eltern
das sind meine eltern mein bruder ist
zwölf jahre alt
mein bruder ist zwölf jahre alt
er ist zwölf jahre alt
meine mutter arbeitet als kassiererin
sie arbeitet als kassiererin sie aber
als kassiererin meine tochter tanzt gern
meine tochter kannst gern
sie tanzt gern
sie tanzt gern mein mann arbeitet als
polizist
mein mann arbeitet als polizist
er arbeitet als polizist
als polizist zahlen 10 bis 40
sarah
zehn bis 40 10 10
11 11 12
13 13 14 14 15 15 16 16 17 17 18 18 19
19 20 20 21 21 22 22 23 23 24 24 25 25
26 26 27 27 28 28 29 29 30 30 31 31 32
32 33 33 34
34 35 35 36 36 37 37 38 38 39 39 40 40
50 50 60 60 70 70 80 80 90 90
[Musik]